[موسيقى]
قبل ان تعلن محكمه العدل الدوليه قرارها
استندت الى الماده الثانيه من اتفاقيه منع
الاباده الجماعيه للتاكيد على ان الشعب
الفلسطيني مجموعه محنيه بموجب الاتفاقيه
كما استندت للماده التاسعه من الاتفاقيه
عينها وبنت على ما نظرت فيه من دفوع
الاطراف المختلفه وقررت انه لا يمكن قبول
طلب اسرائيل رد الدعوه وقالت ان من حق
جنوب افريقيا التقدم بمثل هذه الدعوه
باعتبارها دوله موقعه على اتفاقيه منع
الاباده الجماعيه ومن مصلحتها عدم
انتهاكها كما اكدت المحكمه ان لها صلاحيه
الحكم باجراءات طارئه في دعوى الاباده
الجماعيه ضد اسرائيل وبناء على حيثيات
ساقتها رئيسه المحكمه اعلنت طبيعه
التدابير المؤقته التي خلصت اليها على
اسرائيل وفقا لالتزامها باتفاقيه منع
الاباده الجماعيه وفي فيما يتعلق
بالفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه ان تتخذ جميع
الاجراءات التي في سلطتها وصلاحياتها لمنع
ارتكاب كل الجرائم المذكوره بالماده
الثانيه من الاتفاقيه وان تتاكد فورا ان
قواتها العسكريه لا ترتكب ايا من الافعال
المذكوره بالماده المشار اليها ورات
المحكمه ان على اسرائيل اتخاذ ما بيدها من
اجراءات لمنع ومعاقبه ووقف كل اشكال
التحريض على ارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه ضد
الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه واتخاذ اجراءات
فوريه لتوفير الخدمات الاساسيه والمساعدات
الانسانيه الملحه للفلسطينيين في غزه
واتخاذ تدابير فوريه لمنع تدمير الادله
المتعلقه بمزاعم ارتكاب اباده جماعيه
وقررت المحكمه اخيرا ان على اسرائيل وخلال
شهر رفع تقرير حول كل التدابير التي
فرضتها
المحكمه